it's another small announcement
nevertheless it shows us stress within
the Royal to family I think the key for
Saudi Arabia's diversification and
Mohammad said it is all my 30 years he's
being more aggressive than we've ever
seen him before they've talked about
looking at the non-oil income which was
running around ten billion dollars per
year right now taking it up to a hundred
billion dollars that would take that
dependence of oil from eighty percent
too much lower levels going forward so I
think that just reflects the need for
the diversification and underscores the
importance of the focus on privatization
of some of the key industries with
inside Saudi Arabia but if this takes
time our editor-in-chief John Michael
Thwaite had a great interview with the
deputy Crown Prince of Saudi Arabia
about ten days ago and he was saying
exact that they are diversifying it
they're actually targeting a hundred
billion dollars of revenue outside oil
they're creating a fund but from now
until then they have to continue pumping
because otherwise their outlook is going
to get even worse well I think it goes
to the to the key point there that the
world has shifted because of shale you
cannot run a cartel in the current
environment with the flatness of that
supply curve or the fast cycle nature of
shale so what that points to is that low
cost players like Saudi Arabia need to
go to capacity and grow capacity going
forward and that's really been the
stated goal of not only Saudi Arabia but
most of the low-cost players within the
region so we would argue that growth
through volumes is going to be key as
opposed to thinking about price levels
going forward richard of course a saudi
arabia is crucial for the Middle East
it's crucial when you look at all prices
but this is a radical shift for a
country that's built on petrol dollars
when oil was first found in Saudi Arabia
about eight decades ago is this a
systemic risk if they don't do it right
I think it's a risk but I think it also
gives an indication of perhaps the
future for a lot of similar sovereign
wealth funds you know Norway's been a
pioneer in this and reprofiling away
towards a more diversified global
portfolio and perhaps more realistic
expectations for income I things going
to be a factor in global markets and
where these were these firms invest
they don't invest what will move prices
what is the geopolitics in the stance
that the US should take we've had such
an interesting relationship with Saudi
Arabia where do you see that going with
the next president well you know Tom I'm
going to beg off on that because I'm not
an expert in anything I would say would
be uninformed but I what I will say is I
think the world in the next eight years
is going to look a lot different than
the world in the last 20 or 30 years I
think constellation of forces and
complexity has has changed and the next
president will have his or her hands
full Jeff curry I see this headline Lou
urges IMF to get tough on exchange rate
manipulators which goes to dollar
dynamics into oil do you just presume a
dollar as reserve currency and a weaker
dollar that can stabilize oil prices
well when we think about the currency
that the commodities denominated it
really doesn't matter because it's all
relative prices that drive commodity
prices in the end and the denomination
is not large enough to affect the
currency market so that's why I go back
to the point that currencies and
commodity prices are endogenously
determined let's take copper the price
of copper is not so much really
important as much as the price of copper
bowl to the price of oil in chilean peso
seventy percent of the cost of producing
copper is going to be chilean peso which
is labor and then thirty percent of that
is going to be energy so that relative
price differentials what matter it goes
the point it has to be endogenous